Eric Reid the defensive back for the
49ers took a knee with Colin Kaepernick
and kind enough to join us this morning
Eric good morning thanks for joining us
let me go back to a couple of weeks ago
when did you find out that Colin
Kaepernick was going to sit down during
the anthem um this week I knew he was
gonna do it again because he he told me
you would uh I didn't know he did it
until after the game the first time what
was the reaction in the locker room at
first time I wouldn't say there's muscle
reaction because I don't think many guys
knew that it happened I I wasn't even
found out I think it was the next day
that I even saw the picture of him
sitting down so but he was still after
that you know guys that supporter what
he would he did and his stance on things
you know told him how they felt about it
and he told me that he's had more
in-depth conversations with his
teammates about things other than
footballs and he has his entire career
and so I think that that says a lot
about what he's trying to get
accomplished what made you take a knee
last night and why take a knee and not
[ __ ] well I wanted to show my support
for him and what he's doing because I I
to stare a lot of the beliefs that he
has with the issues that are happening
in this country and we we sat down with
Nate boy ozone green beret and we were
talking to him and he was telling us
about his buddies and how it hurt the
guys that he's been in to war with that
the action that Colin did and so we said
that we wanted to find a way to be more
respectful to the people that felt
disrespected by Collinson down and it
just dawned on as I would have what if
we took a knee and that way you know
we're not wouldn't I be isolating
ourselves from our teammates we wouldn't
be you know sitting down during the
national anthem we were attempting to be
more respectful for the people that felt
disrespected by
sitting and so instead we took a knee to
still so that you know we still want to
bring awareness to the issues that we
have in this country it's been the
reaction from coach Kelly um I thought
coach Kelly give Kong high five when he
got on the bus last night on it's not
something that he addressed as a team i
think is understood in our locker room
that is something bigger than football
and it hasn't divided in us anyway as a
football team um like Colin told me has
actually been positive and with his
relationships with a lot of his
teammates he's been able to have
conversations with guys on a much deeper
level than he's ever been able to thus
far in his career you encouraging other
players to join you or other players
expressed interest in joining you on
that Monday night when you guys open the
season I've got a lot of support from a
lot of other players um I I don't want
anybody to do anything that they're
uncomfortable with um simply telling me
that they support it is enough for me um
I wouldn't pressure anybody to do
anything that they don't feel
comfortable doing so I'm perfectly fun
doing it myself with Colin but if
anybody else does it then that that
supported welcomes will you do it monday
night the season opener I will um I
think and I said before this these
issues are much bigger than the game of
football football is a game and we
respectfully take this position when it
comes to the national anthem because the
bigger cause is bringing awareness to
the issues that we have in this country
it's not meant to disrespect the anthem
is not miss to disrespect the military
whatsoever when it's quite the contrary
I myself and after talking to Colin have
the utmost respect for the people that
serve and put their life on the line for
this country we actually want and we
love this country so much that we want
it to be better and we're simply trying
to bring awareness to those issues and
after talking to nate i mean these
issues are there's a number of them
he was telling us about a homeless
shelter that he goes to and I think he
said it was Philadelphia with guys that
served in the military when they come
back and they don't have any programs to
help them transition into civilian life
and that's a huge issue the people that
fight for our country and fight for our
freedoms come home and they aren't set
up for success to be a civilian and
that's a huge issue and so with issues
like that um police brutality equal
equal pay for women it's a laundry list
of issues in this country that we feel
needs to be addressed and it's not just
us being rebellious against the anthem
that's not what it is we want to get out
in the community and actually affect
change with these situations in these
issues as Eric read the 49ers safety he
took a knee with Colin Kaepernick last
night are you still a player rep for the
niners hi have you heard from the
Players Association and their potential
involvement I haven't heard anything
from them I know we have a meeting on
the 6th or 7th of this month um so it'll
be interesting to see if they have
anything to say about it but I haven't
heard anything from them thus far you've
been attacked on social media as a
result of last night yeah I mean there's
always going to be backlash so you can't
you can't please everybody I think
anybody who's ever still for anything
knows that and so I welcome it because
it lets me know that those people are
seeing what's being done and eventually
you you have to get past the initial
emotions that you have with the action
involved with kneeling while the anthem
has been playing and see the bigger
picture which is the message that is
trying to be conveyed once we get past
the the headline of Colin Kaepernick
sits during the national anthem and you
see why he did it you can respect where
he's coming from why did he wear the
socks during practice that are have the
cartoon with a pig wearing a pull
I don't from what I understand what he
told me is he wore those socks weeks ago
yeah i think if my memory serves me was
doing the outs on sterling events in
louisiana and that event hurt people it
hurt me I mean it shook me to my core
they broke me down to tears and a lot of
emotions come up surrounding that and
that was just I think his way of
expression expressing some frustration
but it is before he took this public
stance on and these are the things he
expects whenever you stand up for
something that's that's was going to
happen people are going to try and tear
you down pick you apart find a reason to
discredit or distract from what you're
trying to accomplish and so he owns up
to that is not shying away from the heat
he has family members at a police
officers so I think if exactly what i
said is people trying to distract away
from the ultimate goal of ways not wait
raising awareness Eric thanks for
joining us and I appreciate it and good
luck with what you guys are trying to
accomplish thank you hi Tara Creed nine
your safety the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]